il est de retour après six ans d'absence
james bond revient au cinéma dans mourir
peut attendre dans la peau du plus
célèbre des espions l'anglais daniel
craig incarne pour la dernière fois 007
nom
avant daniel craig ils sont plusieurs
acteurs à avoir jouer james bond au
cinéma le premier d'entre eux c'est lui
sean connery jette en 1963 l'écossais à
32 ans il vient de tourner bons baisers
de russie avec quand c'est vraiment le
personnage idéal qu un film d'espionnage
et aventure il est très grand visage
sympathique je crois que il doit
beaucoup plaire aux spectatrices après
cinq films sean connery laisse sa place
à un parfait inconnu de 29 ans
l'australien george lazenby
il est très sexy très sûr de lui
après george lazenby sean connery
revient une dernière fois dans la peau
de 0,07 en 1971
en 1973 roger moore lui succède il
devient le plus vieil acteur a débuté
dans le rôle de l'espion à l'âge de 45
ans
et enlève son pistolet quand il fait
l'amour
ça
pourrait être une espionne russe au
total l'anglais joue dans sept films un
record l'un des plus connus c'est
moonraker de lewis gilbert sorti en 1979
ce qui fait courir james bond sortes de
choses les méchants et les jolies filles
qu'est ce qui fait courir roger moore
très peu de chance vraiment quatrième
james bond sur grand écran timothy
dalton en 1986 le gallois tourner au
maroc tuer n'est pas jouer
après timothy dalton pierce brosnan en
1995 l'irlande et reprend le rôle de 007
dans goldeneye de martin campbell
le premier film que j'ai vu de ma vie
c'est à londres en 64 et 7 et goldfinger
j'étais gamin irlandais catholiques j'ai
vu cet immeuble couverte d'or c'était
magique quatre films plus tard pierce
brosnan parce que flambeau à daniel
craig premier james bond blond de
l'histoire en 2006 l'anglais tourner
bahamas casino royale 21e opus de la
franchise on ne refuse pas james bond
c'est une figure emblématique du cinéma
et puis je me suis demandé si je ne fais
pas bon qu'est ce que je vais faire je
peux continuer j'espère d'ailleurs le
faire a joué dans les films que je fais
habituellement quand tu as des filles
comme ça arrive il y a deux possibilités
et j'ai décidé de voir comment ça allait
se passer au total daniel craig incarne
et cinq fois james bond qui lui
succèdera dans la peau de 0,07 les paris
sont ouverts
[Applaudissements]